all right Jordan we actually just got
back from an event we saw FLAC but they
also today just released the skill tree
for flack and all of the characters and
also a trailer so just to catch you guys
up we've seen all the characters and
played all of them now there's a lot of
really interesting things here that we
want to go through with you guys in the
skill tree and also in the trailer so
let's let's start off with the trailer
let's get into it so this is the haunt
trailer they released today it's really
obvious from this trailer that flack is
a robot and say if that wasn't obvious
to you before oh yeah for me it wasn't
so Black has three pets there's a racket
there's a jabber and there's a spider
and now in this trailer all three of
them are up at once but that doesn't
seem like based on the skill tree
something you can do you're probably
limited to one at a time I'd say yeah
just looking at the skill tree it looks
like you could only equip one of the
pets in a slot at a time you can easily
switch between them but they can't all
be equipped at once it seems like the
skill tree and the pets according to the
website are not linked together so you
can go down one skill tree but you can
swap the pet out independent of that
skill tree it seems like you'll be able
to use them when you want them which is
really kind of interesting now it seems
like maybe you you do want to invest in
a one single skill tree up front because
you can get to those look things on the
right where you evolve your animal so
the animals have a couple of different
phases just starting with the Jabar
which is your monkey like companion he's
and he's an armed monkey he has a gun he
starts off with just your simple pistol
but if you get all the way down to your
third level of skills he decides to grab
a shotgun hands if you get to the fourth
level skills he grabs a rocket launcher
which sounds incredibly bad I feel like
he will not take well to being pet when
he's a badass with a rocket launcher and
if you just quickly scroll over to the
spider ant it evolves into a scorcher
spider ant so does a lot more damage and
then it evolves into a spider ant
cowntess which is incredibly powerful
you encounter them I believe in
Borderlands 2
like a mini-boss so to see that now is
just a companion that you can bring into
battle is pretty cool and then finally
if you just look at the scag which is
the good boy the good dog boy which I
believe you can he's such a good boy and
he is he is he's a great I can say that
he evolves into a great horn scag which
is essentially just a larger version of
a scag and then from there he evolves
into an yridian scag which is just a
scag that does elemental damage I think
you and I took a look at the bottom of
the skill tree and this one also seemed
like it had one of the more interesting
yeah dominance
ability that when black just turns to an
enemy he can with his melee turn them to
his side and if the enemy happens to be
a beast character which I assume I'm not
quite sure what that entails I just
assume any enemy that's not a robot
that's like specialty bandit it's double
the time which sounds like it could be
incredibly useful for late in the game
when you're just surrounded by a bunch
of people and you just need another ally
real quick flax a robot he's got
multiple animals that he can take with
him and those animals can apparently be
swapped out at any time independent of
the skill tree most of it has to do with
just traditional stacks of damage
shifting damage between him and his pet
or increasing critical hits okay so
we've played all the characters and we'd
love to tell you a lot more about them
stick to GameSpot because we have a lot
more Borderlands 3 coverage coming to
you alright thanks for watching